[Musique]
le coeur économique des etats-unis va au
ralenti
[Musique]
dans cette ville au taux de chômage
demeure plus élevé qu'ailleurs au pays
des femmes ont choisi d'avancer à
contre-courant le confinement du prétend
venait à peine d'être annoncée quant à
mika squibb a choisi de plonger employés
d'une entreprise technologique
elle a lancé sa boutique virtuelle de
vente de perruques rêve qu'elle
caressait depuis des années ce qui l'a
convaincu le sort réservé à sa mère qui
a perdu son emploi dans un hôtel après
vingt ans de loyaux services
le pari était risqué mais les clientes
ont répondu à l'appel
tu as milk a su profiter de la fermeture
des salons de coiffure considérés comme
non essentiels
la jeune femme n'est pas la seule à
avoir opté pour un changement malgré les
millions perte d'emploi la création
d'entreprises aux etats-unis a connu une
forte augmentation pendant la pandémie
une troisième trimestre de 2020 les
demandes de permis étaient en hausse de
80% par rapport à l'année précédente
parmi ces entreprises qui ont vu le jour
l'épicerie de myriam saint pierre qui a
ouvert ses portes en avril au sommet de
la première vague commercy essentielle
son magasin est installé au coeur d'un
quartier plutôt défavorisé petit oasis
offrant des produits santé dans un
désert alimentaire ou les impacts
économiques de la pandémie pourrait
perdurer
dans un contexte hors du commun les
défis ont été nombreux de
l'approvisionnement en aliments à la
conciliation travail-famille pour cette
mère de deux jeunes enfants s'occuper
des enfants notamment avec justement les
écoles qui étaient fermés et à new york
donc elles sont toujours fermées pour
une bonne partie donc s'occuper des
enfants le foyer et j'en ai vu beaucoup
souffrir de sa valériane 2010 est à la
tête d'une communauté de femmes
entrepreneures expatriés à new york en
réseau qui s'est élargie avec le virage
numérique est posée par la pandémie
à son avis inventivité et solidarité ont
aider ses membres à affronter une crise
dont elles ont durement subi les
conséquences
le fait de s'en rendre compte de le voir
encore une fois de pleine face ça permet
peut-être aussi de travailler davantage
sur certaines choses et enfin d'arriver
à plus d'égalité
[Musique]
la crise sanitaire et économique n'est
pas terminée metallica screen pense déjà
à la suite des choses
la création d'une vraie boutique avec
pignon sur rue à new york puis
éventuellement en californie et en
georgie imagine déjà c'est perruque sur
la tête de clientes dans différentes
régions du pays
comme quoi il n'ya pas que le deuil et
le chômage que la pandémie laissera en
héritage
[Musique]